bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france à l'heure la
manifestation est terminée avec quelques
tensions bien moi que celle qui avait vu
le 21 novembre
oui beaucoup moins qui est important
comme message malgré tout c'est que le
volume des manifestants a diminué et que
comme vous l'avez montré d'ailleurs dans
votre reportage il ya une réaction de la
population qui est plus massive pour
aller recevoir sa sa troisième dose et
vous voyez aussi aux témoignages reçus
c'est tout à fait normal qu'ils aient
des gens il ya une minorité qui a des
doutes encore à cet égard vellas mais
vous voyez très bien que le dispositif
lui tu progresses oui vous parlez du
volume qui était différent c'est vrai
que à peu prés humides personnes
aujourd'hui il y en avait 31 35 mille
ans le 21 novembre est ce que le
mouvement est en train de s'essouffler
il me semble que malgré tout et si les
décisions en belgique ont été
relativement cacophonique et non
coordonnée mais le public dans sa
majorité il faut pas se laisser
impressionner par ce qui assure les
réseaux sociaux et par les manifestants
qui exerce un droit constitutionnel mais
quand vous regardez les sondages et que
vous faites des interrogations dans la
population et il faut voir aussi les
chiffres de vaccination qui sont quand
même très important belgique vous voyez
bien qu'il ya une nette majorité en
faveur d'une stratégie réfléchie
progressive de restriction pour essayer
de freiner cette nouvelle vague de
contamination alors au niveau justement
des restrictions sanitaires mon nez ou
en belgique on en a rajouté un vendredi
comme les autorités l'ont annoncé
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on ne peut
plus faire et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
encore faire en belgique mais assez
écoutés et pratiquement doctorat en
droit pour répondre à vos questions et
lire un arrêté qui est lui même à la
limite de l'illisibilité donc en gros on
a fait 1 ce qui est important ça change
un peu chaque semaine ce qui est
difficile à suivre pour tout le monde il
ya eu plus de restrictions pour ce qui
concerne les écoles mais en même temps
les fermes pas suite donc c'est un peu
compliqué à comprendre la logique mais
néanmoins on voit l'extension dans
l'utilisation du masque le renforcement
des aérations et pour ce qui concerne
les rassemblements à l'intérieur on a
diminué les seuils qui était bien en
gros et il ya les vacances donc le port
du masque obligatoire un des six ans
donc dans les écoles et il ya également
les vacances de noël qui ont été
avancées pourquoi parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que au niveau de la
contamination il y avait peut-être taux
plus fort aujourd'hui au niveau des
enfants aient voté oui il ya des
problèmes dans les écoles qui sont liées
au fait que dès qu'il ya quelques
enfants qui ceux qui ont une
contamination
ou bien les enseignants ça pose des
problèmes d'organisation important n'est
pas du tout comme l'a rappelé van den
broeck la faute des enfants mais c'est
comme ça que ça se passe parce que ça
reste la population la moins vacciner
donc il faut essayer de freiner les
contaminations dans toutes les zones où
elles grandissent ça c'est un premier
objectif est bien évidemment les
autorités comme les experts d'ailleurs
sont assez préoccupés par la venue du
nouveau variant au micron ya dans le
sens d'une certaine anticipation
on veut éviter qu'un variant qui serait
encore plus contaminant ne rencontre pas
de barrière alors tout ça selon les
autorités c'est pour éviter un
confinement est ce que selon vous on
s'engouffre et et des dons de
visionnaire c'est ce vers quoi la
belgique se dirige
effectivement il faudrait être madame
irma ce que je ne suis pas d'autant plus
que je ne connais pas les plans du
variant qui n'a informé personne donc
nous devons pour le moment il faut se
rendre compte qu'il ya partout dans le
monde au niveau mondial la noë metz en
europe dans les grands pays une course
pour essayer d'identifier les effets du
nouveau variant et c'est ça qui va à mon
avis déterminer la réponse des autorités
et le problème d'ailleurs n'est pas
différent en belgique de la france ou de
l'allemagne ou des pays bas nous avons
des difficultés il ya des contestations
qui toi ion clair en termes de
population demeure limitée
il faut essayer au maximum de s'apprêter
à ce qui est annoncé d'ailleurs depuis
l'été on a bien compris tu es l'année
dernière que ceci était une infection
saisonnière
franklin de housses merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur à l'université de
liège et ancien juge à la cour de
justice de l'union européenne